bonsoir philippe aimez vous retrouver
pour évoquer donc cette situation en
espagne on a vu les chiffres
malheureusement son sont guère
reluisants et pourtant à l'instar de la
france d'ailleurs pas de re confinement
c'est quoi c'est l'économie qui prime on
a fait ce choix là bas aussi
bonsoir stéphanie de méru ben il y ait
eu un petit peu une commune une
confusion dans sur ce sujet parce que
cette référence à l'incapacité
économique de l'espagne
évidemment nema n'est pas d'une autorité
gouvernementale c'est ce sont des
commentaires effectivement qui ont été
diffusées dans la presse qui ont été
largement repris au niveau européen mais
ce n'est pas la lecture qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui moi j'aurai une lecture plus
optimiste qui est celle que le l'espagne
et le gouvernement espagnol ont vraiment
trouvé juste mesure juste compromis
entre la préservation des activités
économiques de son pays et les gestes
barrières et on en voit les résultats
c'est un pari qui est en passe d'être
gagné car finalement aujourd'hui les
chiffres qui ont été avancés aujourd'hui
montrent une régression du virus en
espagne et les restaurants sont ouverts
on annonce même la réouverture des
librairies le week end
l'élargissement des périmètres de
circulation du niveau municipal haut
niveau comme arcade qui est ce qui en
fait l'équivalent du canto en france
donc on voit bien que derrière
effectivement ces commentaires
politiques qui ont eu lieu sur la
capacité de l'allemagne à je dirais à
venir en appui économique des activités
il ya une réalité qui est le respect
effectivement des petits commerçants des
activités de tous les jours et qui
aujourd'hui effectivement fonctionne
alors là vous nous intéressait philippe
emmanuelli parce que j'entends déjà nos
restaurateurs français faire des bonds
ça veut dire que vous nous dit en
substance les chiffres là en tout cas
les les tout récents sont plutôt
encourageants malgré tout les
restaurants restent ouverts oui oui je
vous le confirme je vous le confirme
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le
gouvernement espagnol a mis en place une
politique chirurgicale c'est à dire que
nous
arthur des restaurants s'est fait sur
des bases très précises premièrement de
plages horaires
deuxièmement de protocole sanitaire
troisièmement de concentration des
patients dans les restaurants et ça
fonctionne les restaurants ouvrent deux
fois par jour sur des plages horaires
réduite mais qui leur permettent
d'assurer environ 2 service par plages
horaires et ça ne se traduit pas
aujourd'hui par une augmentation des
contaminations
ça veut dire que l'étape sont espacées
comment ça se passe concrètement parce
que je vous cache pas que ça nous
intrigue un petit peu parce que c'est
quand même incroyable pays voisin
l'espagne la france nous dit bah non
c'est dans les restaurants qu'on se
contaminent plus parce que forcément
interactions sociales donc tout et son
contraire
oui c'est un petit peu ça et puis c'est
vrai aussi que les études ne sont pas là
pour véritablement tranché dans un sens
ou dans un autre parce qu'il ya toujours
une nouvelle étude est sorti
scientifique qui est à nouveau a
contredit le fait que les restaurants
était un lieu de contamination
l'expérience espagnole montre
aujourd'hui que le fait de continuer à
une restauration avec encadré avec
effectivement une politique je dirais
dédiée à cette activité économique
fonctionne et il ya également le
triptyque intel tester protéger isolé
jamais si je le dis dans le bon sens
pardonnez moi c'est le cas également en
espagne on continue a testé massivement
toujours les tests pcr où on a ouvert
justement à d'autres formes de tests à
écouter aujourd'hui on est massivement
mais l'ambiance est clairement à la
vaccination est aujourd'hui le directeur
de la santé dans sa conférence de presse
a annoncé que l'ensemble des
pensionnaires de maisons de retraite
étaient vaccinés dans leur totalité et
c'est un grand soulagement ici parce
qu'on sait que manifestement ça va se
traduire effectivement dans les courbes
de mortalité dans les prochaines
semaines alors objectif 70 % de vacciner
avant l'été ça vous semble crédit
possible une épée manuel dit on sait
combien il ya de problèmes de pénurie de
vaccins en europe
oui écoutez l'espagne pour le moment
fait la course en tête puisque lé
environ le cinquième ou sixième pays en
avance dans la vaccination de sa
population elle et elle devance
notamment largement la france avec
environ 3 5% de la population
actuellement vaccinés contre environ 2
86% la population en france
donc oui la spana vraiment la volonté
d'atteindre cet objectif et vous le
savez est bien effectivement l'arrivée
en force du vaccin spoutnik dans la
course au vaccin est disponible
effectivement ici suscite de nouveaux
espoirs
oui effectivement le gouvernement
espagnol qui s'est dit disposé à
utiliser spots nick v ça veut dire que
l'espagne aussi attend avec une forme
d'impatience la validation d'un agence
européenne de médicaments
eh bien oui ce pique nique est en passe
de devenir des vaccins les plus sexy de
l'union européenne et aujourd'hui plus
rien ne s'oppose à l'arrivée de spoutnik
si ce n'est effectivement l'autorisation
de l' agence européenne
mais on voit bien qu'ici les autorités
espagnoles seront les premières à
réclamer ce vaccin s'il agence du
médicament européen le valide
merci en tout cas philippe emmanuelli
mais c'est un français exerçant en
espagne d'avoir été avec nous pour
évoquer donc la situation espagnole
merci à vous